welcome to this video playing Michael
Myers with black yeah playing a little
bit more than Sicilian recently going
for this Kalashnikov impossible okay the
Russell limo yeah I don't really know 94
Quincy seven there are many many
possible ways to play that let's see I
don't want to get into huge time
pressure here early I wonder this is
actually correct there is there is a
line like that Bishop c4 no is teaching
okay
yeah this whole line is risky for black
quite obviously as I'm neglecting
development considerably but a pawn is a
pawn and at the moment I don't have any
weaknesses simply because I haven't
moved many points so let's see if I can
make this work I have to catch up with
developments out pretty quickly okay
let's have a let's have a quick just a
brief thought about this why should I
put this queen where is it relatively
solid maybe over here
if I'm really really lucky I get in b6
Bishop e7 yeah this was what I was
thinking but yeah anyway way out said b6
Bishop e7 would be great but I don't
really think I get this in hmm yeah how
else do i get the bishop into play d5
and Bishop d7 maybe would still be great
to put it on the diagonal probably
impossible to accomplish yeah impossible
really I had to do something like that
okay but now I can take and put the
bishop here for Bishop c6 intending d
for which would win the exchange so he
prevented that can I get the rooks
traded now or the rook traded rook c8
yeah that looks very very okay if he
goes rookie 7 and think I was
interesting move but ok Queen age six
right yeah keep it keep it very simple
get the Queen traded or get it activated
if he goes like Queen d6 I can take and
play Queen d2 activating the Queen now
this is just a pawn really for nothing
for not much
one important point is that his bishop
is really not any good my bishop wants
his six doesn't look great but it's not
in any way worse than the b3 bishop yeah
and I get Queens traded no I mean he can
theoretically speaking play Queen III to
keep them on but then I have Bishop b5
activating my my bishop yeah so to take
or not to take I think out he again
because I get the only open file and I
get the bishop here should I check first
actually I maybe check first check and
then then the bishop to reform check
oh so he allows me to take them okay I
can also activate King first it's a very
nice position we have everything under
control chatham like that getting
getting those pawns rolling ok Bishop to
d7 this is something to watch out for ok
let's just prevent it for the time being
okay just gain gain the space prevent
Bishop a form I don't really need to
rush anything here back here probably
yeah it all looks nice but how exactly
am I going to win this not clear it's
not clear to me and I don't see a very
straightforward win yet okay some some
possible f forum but how also f4 and g4
as possible maybe I should really get
all the porns into the flame
f-for takes and gphone yeah probably cat
holding returning one pawn and intending
to push h4 g3 get the majority here h5
g4 majority rolling so g3 or not should
be okay yeah yeah I thought rook e1
should win time more Jack White resign
yeah just as the bucket was about to
play g2 yeah so interesting it was a
very greedy approach grabbing this pawn
I think here's he falls actually the
move that is normally played but I'm not
an expert on this I mean it's a very
greedy approach black as losing time but
grabbing stuff I thought c4 is the way
it since us again can spar off with
whiting and spittle echo or something
this this is stuff like that I cannot
really remember it clearly something
like that okay so i took this and and of
course it's a ton of Queen moose but I
don't know blacks position is without
any any clear weakness as mentioned and
the way it went the computer actually
wants to grab on be to being very greedy
but okay I'd like to have some some
things developed
Green out so yeah Queen f6 was also
possible Jack what is this why
definitely has compensation for the pony
does he have enough compensation
probably yes does he have more
compensation I don't really know the
computer says something like minus 0.3
0.4 this kind of thing but what he did
is simply this is too too too simple I
mean this is not good he has to do
something more aggressive more more more
more fighting this move to prevent
Bishop d7 maybe like a six something
like that that keeps me back at with my
with my bishop on c aid here the the
worst is over here i don't really
believe in enough compensation of the
computer agrees minus 0.6 this is pretty
clear and now i get i get this stuff
trade at all here I could have done
something even better yeah the computer
is greedy as usual and here it's really
justified the the thing is next position
is like a rock here the bishop one c6
might just look like a tall porn but it
covers everything and I'm grabbing
material so that sits nice okay I just
was focused on getting the Queen's off
and this is the position is really am a
win it's just a matter of being being
precise I don't think I played it in the
most I don't know forceful manner but I
always kept a fantastic advantage oh I
hit f4 here why oh that's a neat actor
Jack that's in any texture I didn't see
that if he takes rook
Jack and Annie King jealous check
winning the the bishop chatter like this
okay I was just focused on my main plan
which was using the the pawns their
check yeah taking again was good I
didn't see rook f1 check and then work
on the third-ranked I was just seeing
this but this wins as well but it really
does check you know you can do it into
something like that I wonder what is the
most precise way to do it rookie one is
actually quite neat threatening the mate
well what a position yeah that was very
nice enough of like okay I hope you
enjoyed this game thanks for watching